without the supreme computers that we
have today we could not have developed
the vaccines that we are using today for
for helping us cope with the covert 19
at the
mimic
that's because there is
supercomputers and circuit computers
need super chips and that's what we do
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
we're about to talk about chip design
and semiconductors and i'm really
excited for this episode with sandy
saper asic design manager at ready group
sandy saper joined reddy in 2020 as asic
and fpga design manager he brings over
20 years of experience in managing
complex socs for wireless communications
and automotive applications his
experience encompasses all aspects of
the soc development cycle from
requirements specifications architecture
design verification circuit back end and
silicon validation
sandy has a proven record of managing
multi-disciplinary development teams and
execution of projects efficiently and
effectively prior to joining ready sandy
was director of engineering at very
sense before that he was r d department
manager at freescale semiconductors
sandy holds a bsc in electrical
engineering from the technion institute
of technology in haifa israel
and talking about chip design
semiconductors you know engineering at
the end
designing the thing that the things that
power
you know consumer behavior
everywhere we go
and kind of a black box for me until
recently and and i kind of fell in love
with it with what's happening with chip
design recently and and and i'm really
looking forward to hearing your personal
experience you know your own curiosity
and interest in the field and what it's
actually like to design chips but before
that i'd love to hear a little bit about
yourself your career journey and how you
even got into chip design in the first
place okay thank you very much
er well i'm sandy saber i've been 30
years in the
development of chips
i now i manage a a team a hardware team
that
designs and develops chips for the
semiconductor industry
i work at ready
which is a private company in israel we
have
200 engineers in the company
half of the company is the hardware
under my in my team and the other half
is the software under the software
manager
which i'll get into later and to explain
to you how important that is and the
advantage that we bring
into the market that we have in under
the same roof hardware and software
um
that's a good question how did i get
into that i was always interested in in
electricity as a teenager
and um when i signed up for the
university i said okay let's go into
electricity
it seems that it was back in the
the 80s 1980s
and i said that's where i want to be
i had no idea what chips were then
uh but during my studies i started to
learn about electricity and
all the amazing things that it does and
it started to learn about chip design
and it just
we clicked the two of us clicked me and
chip design we clicked and ever since
then i've been in uh developing chips
and
from the start
and i've been in there as i said i've
been in the uh
now is this
i have to ask the
the curiosity
and the interest for electricity and
ship design
did it stem from
mainly the
you know the academic side of things the
challenge side of things or
what what did you understand about the
where where the world was going and how
how big of a role this was going to play
into society this idea of chip design
what had more wait for you um
i was more into the
listen to the academics and more into
the
hands-on
and
do it you know we have an idea get it
done
and so uh
it's a good question michael cause i
really didn't think that uh back then
as a
in my early twenties
where this was going to uh
where it was really going back then
the technologies were
in their infancy and
the chips that were being done in those
times were very
simple compared to what is going on
today
um
but
i would say that
i had the insight maybe you could say
and this is the area i wanted to get to
and we started you could see in the
beginning uh when it finished the
university they're already
low end microcontrollers
for simple tasks
and
for computers just then the first
laptops the
the first uh
desktops when the laptop was back and
the first desktops were being
uh produced
uh
and uh
you could you could there was
there's murphy's law if you know it
murphy's law means every year or two
there's another shrink where you can get
you can pull you can combine more and
more
in in one single chip
and
uh as we know the development
i think that's i think moore's law but i
also love it you're right sir you're
great moore's law exactly
you're correct
murphy's law is what happens to me every
day when i leave the house that's for
sure though so it's moore's law and it's
been going on ever since right and we've
been cramming more and more
uh
more and more functions in every chip
which has enabled us to get where we are
today and
um cramming more and more performance in
a single chip
is more and more challenging for the
design engineers for the architects
and for the electronic engineers that
have to meet that challenge
okay
and uh
right and and why is so
sandy you know very in a very um basic
sense
why is it critical to today's world why
is chip design
still relevant to what's happening today
because we're you know i'm looking at
you know this magnificent device you
know the iphone or any or you know my my
earphones and i have these tiny tiny
chips that seem to be doing miraculous
things why what what what advancements
do you still have artificial
intelligence it's just starting now
super computing is just stunning you
know it's it's there
and we work on chips that are serving
the artificial intelligence and sucum
computer markets right
and
you meet artificial intelligence every
day
face recognition voice recognition for
example and
super computing for uh for medical okay
without the super computers that we have
today we could not have developed
the vaccines that we are using today for
for helping us cope with the covert 19
at the mimic
that's because there is
super computers and circuit computers
need super chips and that's what we do
[Music]
fantastic okay tell me a little bit
about ready absolutely it is uh it's
like i said a company that has hardware
and software and when you want to
develop a
uh
a chip for the high-end mascot or even
for the low-end mask that you need to
know you come with requirements and we
understand your requirements
and we have a
there's a lot of disciplines
in in developing a chip
and it starts off with understanding
your requirements to meet the
performance that you need
to meet your price that you need and to
meet your power that you need especially
today on in the
in the handsets and mobile power is
critical
and
and so you we have to have a team that
understands the requirements and can
execute on the performance that you need
and there are a lot of disciplines to
make a uh to make a a chip that meets
the requirements
it starts off with the architecture how
do i put how do i even put these all
these blocks together so that they will
function
and with each other what's going to be
in hardware and what is going to be in
software is very critical
hardware is
thousands of times faster than software
and and still you want to be able to
enable the software because software is
what controls what we need
etcetera but there is always there's
always um
uh
certain areas and features
that that
a customer needs that has to be in
hardware and that's where
we in ready
uh can can um
decide for you for the customer what
what can be in hardware and what can be
in software we um
we understand what the performance that
you need and we do the partitioning
and
calculate what has to be in hardware and
what can also be in software the more
that's in software the more versatile
your solution can be
and but you won't meet your performance
because a lot of it has to be in
hardware okay
and then there's the so the architecture
team decides how we're going to put this
chip together
and to meet the performance
and works and it can work on it for
depending on the complexity of the chip
between a month three four five months
half a year
to make sure that we we are gonna and
the end product is going to meet what
you need
and then there's a design team which
have their expertise on how to design
each actual block to meet the
performance that you need meet the
frequency meet the power you meet the
throughput bandwidth we're talking about
bandwidth how much else how much speed i
need to download and you need to hear me
and has to be real-time and then after
the design works and and has finished
the design this needs to be fully
verified verificate fully verified so
there's a large we have a good
and high quality verification team to
make sure that your
uh that what we have designed is going
to fully work and there are no bags
there's zero bugs we cannot allow bags
uh in our um in our chips and i'll tell
you that later why why it's so critical
that it's fully verified and then we
have to change all the code that was
written we have to
translate that into the physical chip
okay
and then there's a team the team there
that does the um translation what we
call compile
into the physical
chip
and then we have to validate that the
physical
meets the requirements mainly of of
speed the clock frequency
and the power
um
and then after that every stage that i'm
telling you about takes a few months
depending on the size of the chip
smaller chips can this time but the
larger teams the ones for the
artificial intelligence in the future
take
can take more time
and and then we have to validate that
what we have done
is exact
and then we then we ship it off to the
factory
and when we ship something off to the
it costs millions of dollars millions of
dollars depending on the on the process
it costs millions of dollars to just get
into the and prepare
the the chip for the factory for the fan
we call them fabs okay
um
so
yes i've heard about that before uh
oh yes now i understand
like the highest technology um
factories that they really have in the
world
super clean super clean super
uh
um
high quality very high quality so here's
the first thing i cannot
ship a chip that has a bag because it's
going to cost me a million dollars to
fix millions
millions dollars to fix it if i don't if
i don't do it correctly plus
the schedule the the time it takes to
fabricate a high end
chip in the fab can take three to four
months and you want to get there time to
market is critical
so
you will only if god forbid you have a
bug in your chip you will only detect
that when you get the silicone after for
five months that's why it's critical
that we have uh
high quality teams that make sure that
there are no bugs in the float and
that's what we have it at ready a
excellent team that does the
verification the design
the architecture
and the final product there and then
after it's gone through all the
stages in the factory it needs to be
packaged and then we receive the chip
and we validate that what we
uh before we ship it to the customer we
validate that it meets all the
performance
that we designed it for
and
meeting the frequency power
uh
before we ship it to the customer and
that can also take
a few weeks to validate that everything
is
perfect
and that god forbid you don't have a
field failure
i i think it's incredible and i can
imagine how
software you know i'm i'm coming from
the software world and you know i was
taught
yeah you know if
as long as the bug is not you know it's
is not
huge
ship it you know get users to start
using it and then roll an update in a
few hours once you start getting some
feedback but there's no reason not to
ship at least part of the features but
here you're saying the whole process is
so lengthy and complicated and requires
such
you know such a detail and such
orientation to detail that if you ship a
bug the cost of the time to market that
cost in dollars to revisit the stores to
perhaps even recall things and to fix
them is so grand that this is that that
and and it sounds like the amount of
detail that you're dealing with is an
incredible amount i mean then these
chips are meant to run the software
right and our men to integrate into our
into our lives or into some complicated
machinery and so i'm i'm imagining that
if my if i thought my software was
complicated and had bugs you know
designing chips
to is the requirements and that's why we
have we need good skilled engineers
high quality design high quality
verification
and execution of translating it into
into the hardware
it's uh
where you need a good high quality team
and
and managers to manage to manage that
everything is
is in
fitting each other everything comes on
time
everything is working together in good
harmony to make sure that it's
what we call
till the end until it works
until we ship it off to the to the fact
that
right
so
the day-to-day
of a chip engineer and the chip designer
i come to work in the morning
what do you do
what is what does a chip designer do
when they get to the office in the
morning michael
uh
after having the first cup of coffee
it's very it's great interaction with
your co-workers is very important
to understand the requirements and how
do i implement them how do i implement
the requirements
so that it's efficient
and it will function
and uh
there's minimum
chance of the of a bag so the most
uh
the understanding you go to your work
understand
uh
what is the functionality that i have to
implement
uh in this block
or
if it's a verification engineer
and how am i going to efficiently
test or verify
that what the design engineer did and
what the architect has defined that we
have to do
how am i going to write the code
that is going to verify that the design
is really clean and we have tools
that we use the more experienced
engineers
know how to
effectively use these tools and they
write the code of the verb what we call
verification test patterns
and
a lot of automation is in the process we
always think how
part of our part of the engine engineers
job is also see how can we do this more
efficiently because as i told you before
every generation gets more and more
complicate complicated because we can
put in more and more we can cram in more
and more
features and performance so we always
we're always in the back of our mind
thinking how can i do this more
efficiently next time or how can i do it
even more efficiently now
and how do we we develop
tools
of hand-on tools that we use to develop
to develop to improve the development to
improve how we do verification and much
more and
more and more efficiently
which is very important since there's
the demand for resources is is high
and the more efficient you are
also the the better it's the the the
cost to develop is uh is much more um
feasible and challenged and
and challenging
so
revisiting the initial part of our
conversation which we were talking about
the the relevance of the field to today
if we're looking at where the world is
headed and you know i'm
i'm looking at a lot of my my friends
and people very are very you know very
very quickly quoting mark andreessen's
software's leading the world and you
know obviously um computer science is
one of the most popular degrees in in
most universities
where if as we're as we're you know
transitioning to the future and where is
where is semiconductors positioned
with my generation with the younger
generation as opposed to let's say
software or other fields
because honestly i don't hear enough or
as much about semiconductors in my
day-to-day as i would like to and just
now i'm i'm properly getting exposure
one basically to the awesome part of the
axiom is that
software
has to run on hardware okay
that's the basics
i always tell that to my software
colleagues without us you couldn't
develop anything
uh so where do i think it's going in the
future i think that we're we are just
going to have to um
uh
think about supercomputing and how do we
uh manage
to
er
weak this
there's a
[Music]
upper border how much can we really cram
into one chip
and we need to think also us as the chip
designers how do i uh
think of
super computing in other words uh
and supporting
multiple chips
okay and that started already
multiple chips where where we have to uh
distribute
all the performance requirements not
only in one chip but on a farm of chips
okay
and how we're going to do that in the
future communication between the trips
chips is very critical
which is also being uh worked on
and uh
that's the way i see it going forward
forward
we are going to keep on developing chips
but because the demand is high we are
now have to think about how we have more
than one chip in the system multiple
chips in the system how are they going
to communicate with one another so that
we can meet the higher demand for
performance
fantastic
and sandy i really want to thank you for
the time and the effort and the energy
i learned a lot and
really enjoyed this conversation so
thank you very very much for joining me
and best of luck with the you know
everything that you're doing and it
sounds fascinating and i can't wait to
learn more about the field myself and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
very much thank you michael for having
me and i'll be glad to come back
whenever you want
[Music]